it's amazing where does he think he can
go
i do not know it's going to fall off
oh [ __ ]
here we go
it's that's what needed to happen
honestly
he wasn't coming down and he was gonna
jump
it sounds like the individual is on the
ground and law enforcement is taking it
into custody
he's still conscious he just has a
little cut on the on his cheek
poor guy can't feel anything but he's so
upset
you know he's just so scared he doesn't
know what's going on he probably thinks
aliens are taking him into custody
oh
okay
is
i honestly doubt it not that i'm aware
of no okay did you change planes
no he didn't get to the door
they may take us back to the gate to
reinspect it but i don't see that
happening but then again
that's not an official panic has to
reset that
which won't take long it's not crazy
very good well in the hospital he can
undergo detox
right and they can give him a sedative
to deal with whatever aggression
he has
well that was exciting never had
anything like that happen on a plane
before i mean she said she's been in
attendance for 30 years and has never
seen anything like
they're this i think that's a good idea
off the yeah sure you're all aware
they've got them in custody
yeah we're gonna get everything buttoned
up
at this point do you want to be down
by here okay but that's better than
totally changing
well it's gonna have to get some more
gas so give us about
five